Eric Palacios from Eric Palacios and  Associates the sponsors of this next  segment shares what the penalties are  for stealing something in Nevada  Palacios welcome to the legal minute  today's question is what are the  penalties for stealing in Nevada Petty  lushney is intentionally stealing  someone else's property valued at less  than twelve hundred dollars this crime  is a misdemeanor and the penalties are  as follows up to a six-month jail  sentence finds up to a thousand dollars  and you will have to pay restitution for  any losses that the theft caused to the  victims I'm Eric Palacios this has been  the legal minute  give Eric Palacios and Associates a call  at  702-444-7777law.com we'll be right back